forty seconds of three Sony logos the
world we live in
seriously are all animated movies
particularly the ones required to begin
with disembodied narration I mean I've
guess they've got a voice actor and a
mic and say what the hell hey which one
of you assholes took a break from
texting to make and throw this paper
airplane goddammit if you're gonna be a
part of this cliched image of current
adolescence you better get the hell back
onto tinder that's my home tech stop
with us
wait why isn't it called emoji bill or
emoji would this assumes all text lives
here but there are no numbers or letters
to be found here each of us does one
thing and we have to nail it every time
yeah but why does the fortune cookie get
the crack wise and the elephant can
later joke with the laughing guy about a
text the rules of this place make no
fucking sense Merry Christmas
it's still September Tim first off why
does the Christmas tree have an actual
name and why does it be Tim and does it
matter that it's September this fortune
cookie asshole has clearly never seen a
retail store after August Cryer always
has to cry has to or decides to and why
exactly yes I know it's the entire
foundation of what we're going to
loosely call a plot here but a few
seconds ago you said for the faces the
pressure is on why would the pressure be
on if they have no choice and
furthermore why does it matter what they
do outside of the cubes that's the only
time they're required to be on also hang
up not only do the emojis have a fully
functional lottery system but they use
actual money as currency isn't money
itself an emoji I know you can't also
based on the silly putty appendages will
continue to see throughout this travesty
pretty sure the audience is the only one
who's boned why is he trying on ties
emojis don't work clothes and even if
they did are you trying to tell me this
untied shoe here would even fit those
tiny feet and this world must be
confusing are edible doughnuts a thing
here our people tempted to eat these
babies what kind of business monkey
business you it's been almost 30 seconds
since we heard a low-quality punt is
that the time hey my eyes are up here
pal
hate what iris numbers his genitals and
don't you look at the whole clock when
telling the time also how is he not used
to this elephant farts elfin parts let's
all laugh at the elephant parts freak
protagonists in a kids movie is bullied
for being different cliche
my parents are total pros parents great
now I have to think about how emojis
reproduce can only identical emojis hook
up to produce the same emoji offspring
and how does that even work looks on
when an eggplant emoji loves a taco
emoji very much whoa I'm a ton of
questions about what just happened here
how do these poop emojis even use the
restroom did they just murder one of
their own
what were they flushing wooden bathrooms
be like torture chambers for them or
wait did he just birth his son our
bathrooms their birthing centers should
we wash our hands ha ha ha ha you movie
come on dad if you really think you're
ready
so in this universe the parents get to
decide who goes on the job should the
hiring and firing be done by the
scanning company we are all of these new
emojis starting work on the same day the
hell they replaced a huge chunk of their
workforce overnight all of these cubes
are already full and there's even poop
senior sitting in his so where are these
new assholes supposed to go because I
was the original emoji were you because
I'm pretty sure the first group of
emojis were all released at the same
time unless you mean the emoticon but
we've already seen that those are
different and considered the elderly in
this universe Plus on this phone you all
probably came pre-installed together so
tell me again why you're in charge
there's nothing like getting scammed
for the first time damn movie did you
have to make the emojis getting scanned
for the first time creepy in the
nosebleeds I'm standing right here
words hurt yeah but the nose isn't
bleeding so what's the offense here jeez
it's like the writers were looking at a
page of emojis and said hey we haven't
used the nose yet how can we shoot horn
in a reference I know the movie needs to
show these assholes doing stuff other
than getting scammed but why the hell
aren't they always in there cute Alex is
not sure how he wants to play this just
because he's scrolling through the
options he could be looking for a
specific emoji but this announcer
purports to know his actual thoughts
dammit this movie wants to be inside out
so bad we are go format something not
explained and all that explained arising
is how on earth all this getting every
emoji to their cube orienting the
Machine and doing the scan happened so
quickly on the user side is there a time
distortion does the time flow with a
different rate in the phone is gene
actually Matthew McConaughey is he going
to leave his own daughter Oh
mr. poop can apparently only speak in
poop related references it's kind of
like the dude that works as a personal
trainer and that's all he can talk about
elevator platform that got him in the
cute can someone tell the movie that
these scenes of slow-motion hilarity are
supposed to be used for actual funny
moments malfunction
so I guess Alex who's supposedly
addicted to using his phone and was
literally just texting is taking a
convenient break from using emojis while
all this plays out right I am a
malfunction technically you're correct
which is the problem with the screen
movie you said at the very beginning
that these characters have one job
apiece I'm always happy oh right hashtag
truth is there an emoji for the
combination of anger eye rolling and
bored them all together because if there
is that should be the text for the rest
of this fucking video movie went to
great pains to show us high five
subterfuge to get into the favorites
club so how did gene get in here so
easily
welcome to the loser lounge where the
emojis who never get used hangout never
used
that's eggplant and considering their
user as a male who just graduated junior
high there's no way that emoji is left
unused they were trying to leave me you
what's so important about you they'd
send out an entire team of bots the dude
high-five was at the event where gene
fucked up all the machinery of the
emojis but has no clue why they'd wanted
to lead him it's that had better not be
my leftover Chinese food wait is the
abandoned luggage emoji eating actual
leftover Chinese food or is this an
emoji of Chinese food and if it's an
emoji of Chinese food does that mean the
Chinese food emoji is also in the losers
lounge and what the fuck is up with the
pizza Pete has gotta be an incredibly
popular emoji do you have any idea what
it's like to be demoted to this pit of
despair yeah yeah I'm starting to think
I do
just find a hacker and get reprogrammed
one of the princess emojis left the
phone altogether I'm sure the hacker
that helps her do that could easily
reprogram you
the names jailbreak why does hi-5 even
know any of this did he spend the last
few days in the Wikipedia app studying
up on wyldstyle
I mean jailbreak sure they were asleep
on the couch a little while ago but they
definitely would've woken up during this
trip did hi-5 and gene drug these two
where is he even storing those some sort
of invisible back pouch hour-hand emojis
marsupials and other finger puppets also
emojis can someone explain the goddamn
rules of this universe
let the Silicon Valley product placement
commits being crackle what kid would
have crackle instead of Netflix or HBO
go did he specifically want to watch
Jupiter ascending and that was the only
service that carried it there are no
barriers to getting in and out of these
apps why isn't this cross-pollination
happening all the time it's not like the
boundary was way the hell out of the way
just a short walk from the center of
text Ovilus they like him and that's
what matters in this life popularity oh
good rather just have a real friend
that's right the ping emoji movie is
trying to sneak some serious social
commentary into its narrative just
because one of the six writers has a
problem with how Facebook is used to
follow those meds so not only was
smiling and watching this camera at the
exact time that the bot spotted the Miz
the plan to follow them only just came
to her also nothing about these BOTS
told us that they had cameras in the
first place
what else do they do that we're not
aware of turnout a liquid metal also
just a reminder that alex has continued
to not use any emojis since the
destruction of the pond thinking this
place can get a little rough yep you can
tell how rough this place is by the
extremely dangerous early 80s hair metal
cover band oh geez I thought the
conversation just got dumber
Rando pirate troll that for some reason
requires eyeglasses would be excellent
at cinemasins
internet trolls just ignore them exactly
our internet trolls inside the piracy
app again I can buy emojis BOTS viruses
and such but aren't internet trolls
actual human beings actually I think I
just answered my own question
wait the bots literally just identified
a virus and did nothing would it take
too much time to eliminate this mother
come the how long the spots have been
easily eliminating fools left and right
in this scene alone but the one that
actually spots gene takes as much time
to charge his weapon is the death star I
should probably give up trying to
understand the dimensional physics of
this world but exactly how did they
navigate sideways but end up falling
downward alright because one of them
needed to land in a candy crush level so
we could spend another five minutes on
blatant product placement that serves
zero story purpose I have a sugar
addiction and it's a very serious finger
head that's racist also apparently
because James Corden is overweight all
the characters he voices must have some
sort of food addiction I guess he's Jack
Black now we have to match up the candy
so the gene will drop to the bottom
he'll be seriously includes a game
tutorial one third of the way into this
movie and we just now rejoin the real
world protagonist who we then won't see
again for another thirty minutes I
believe in the existence of actual
sentient emojis sooner than I believe an
actual human being would immediately
answer a customer service line whoa they
made this way harder than it had to be
when the board started all they had to
do was move this yellow to the left to
clear the yellows which would also clear
the dropping rats leaving just this blue
to move over and clear the blues two
moves with no risk what so maybe I crush
a little you know all these other apps
like WeChat and Facebook took up limited
space even text apples was small enough
that gene could get to the border in a
matter of minutes but candy crush is
supposed to be the size of a set piece
in Lord of the Rings but first we need
to get uploaded to the cloud that's
where we'll find the source code to
reprogram you what I don't know if it's
possible to reprogram a fucking emoji by
using a cloud service but I do know that
this is a cheap and convenient excuse to
get them off the phone and into a whole
new environment
we're in candy crush ops I know a
shortcut to just dance which is right
next to Dropbox where we can get
uploaded to the cloud could you be more
product place here also why even worry
about a shortcut when it's just like
four blocks down it's not like time or
space have any sort of meaning in this
universe anyway and why did they even
have to go through an app to get to
another app when there are paths to
those apps isn't like a city grid with
avenues and streets I wanted to see cuz
it was my idea you know women are always
coming up with stuff that men are taking
credit for but he's a ping emoji with
very little indication he's masculine
does she see a penis that I'm missing
my precious it's as if this movie heard
my earlier joke about Lord of the Rings
and then realized there was yet another
pop-culture reference they could cheaply
cram down in there I think we should go
our separate ways Mel wait she's
divorcing him now while they're out
looking for their son and how do these
fucking things even get married in the
first place and now enough do they
procreate this movie finally broke me
with its stupidity add 50 sins to this
fucking thing high five even asked
jailbreak about doing this for him sure
he told gene that this was his plan but
that was way before they met her just
because she's a hacker doesn't mean you
have automatic consent dammit I was
trying to think of a clever way to call
out the impossibility of this stupid
fucking scene but all I saw was a
white-hot rage so let's add ass in here
and move on while my systolic blood
pressure still measures within three
digits high 5 don't do it this goes on
for some time no matter what we can't
turn it on every other app anyone's
walked into has already been operational
why does this one all of a sudden have
to be turned on from the inside
even though hi-5 hasn't been shown
obsessively pressing buttons throughout
this whole journey this is supposed to
provoke a laugh god damn it every app
has been turned on during this trip
including the very loud candy crush but
this is the one that gets the bots
attention this movie with everything
that can fuck also in the time that it
took the bots to realize the Just Dance
app was turned on gene and the crew
could easily have made it across this
reasonably sized room to the portal even
before the game kicked in ruby includes
two game tutorials come on everybody can
dance
apparently this includes emojis because
movie once our disbelief so suspended
that it pulls a hammy hi-five somehow
advances in the game despite doing none
of the moves that it requires nice I
always wondered what that loud sound was
I heard in late July 2017 and now
realize it was several million parents
sitting in movie theaters collectively
groaning at the scene Christina Aguilera
apparently only agreed to do this part
if she was allowed to shout all her
lines at the top of her lungs seriously
this movie is like 78 minutes before the
credits but there were multiple people
that signed off on this super long dance
sequence that has nothing to do with the
rest of this movie god damn it why did
this make so much money
also these King BOTS have been flying
everywhere is their primary mode of
transportation so why do they need to
use the game to advance or they could
just shoot those ping laser
out of their hands like they've been
doing this whole time and that deletion
will provide the steps towards our goal
instead of immediately making everything
disappear G is the bot doing rather than
shooting the emojis like they're
supposed to this asshole grabs hi-5 and
does a tandem hans gruber off the
platform and they're all here to get
gene anyway so why would even with high
five in the first place
wait where's high five are you kidding
me less than 30 seconds ago you
literally dropped him into the void and
screamed no how are you even asking this
question right now no way we can't go
without my five that's my friend down
there what about this arrangement led to
high five and gene being friends sure
high five helped him find jailbreak he
was doing that mostly for his own
benefit wait Alex only shuffled two apps
when did Salida just dance
but somehow the science app or whatever
that is moved all the way from a
different screen to here and what is
that a before we heat one right after
the candy crush scenario nerd emoji said
his appointment is for tomorrow it
didn't take them an entire fucking day
to go through the tunnels and play the
just dance game I mean how hard is it to
prep a timeline that you specifically
mentioned the illegal upgrade you mean
that thing that you somehow have stashed
away for this very specific situation
that you could in no way have known was
about to happen
yay a bunch of people are hitting the
promenade I think Eddie might be there
too that's perfect movie remembers to
feature this F story about Alex asking a
girl out for the fall dance because it
needs a break from the emotional
complexity of the emojis playing a
goddamn dansgame also what fucking kid
uses the word promenade did you realize
that on the first emoji set a woman can
either be a princess or a bride but wait
smiling is a girl mrs. MS a girl plus I
thought you just were what you were in
the logic of the universe you weren't a
princess because you're a girl you're a
princess because you're a princess you
know I think you're pretty cool just the
way you are um are they gonna start
because if so I'm not sure that would
make this movie better or worse okay
they got the rope from the magical boat
on the Spotify app where they find a
fucking winch gene are you instagramming
I swear to God movie just eat Sir
Patrick Stewart and die kind of sorcery
is this does instagram capture 3d
encapsulations of a square mile radius
does mrs. men somehow have memory of all
this she the NiO of her own metrics
sorry it's this movie it's eating my
brain let's go find her
together am I supposed to be full of
some sort of emoji emotion here they've
been apart for what 15 minutes why don't
you come back to text Appa listen we can
talk through our differences okay
okay seriously why is smiler in control
of the entire phone the bots are hers
and they apparently control the
functions of every app so why would she
have total authority shouldn't the
dictator be embedded into the Settings
app or something
also why isn't this upgraded asshole
shooting them right now the entire movie
has been the bots trying to kill gene
and now that he's in their sights
smiler wants to bring them all the way
back to text tapas can't get in it's
illegal malware and this app is secure
and also incredibly convenient to the
block also an email app isn't secured
despite eating all that Beckett candy
crush the candy corn is the only item
that hi-5 continues to regurgitate Jean
survives this and this book this book
this Bulls this boat this boat this
tomfoolery and this bull I'd probably
use the name of a girl I like I've been
all over the phone he's never mentioned
a girl the fucking he was just texting
with her yesterday what is her name
it was Tina Karen March this is this
movie in a nutshell an over long
repetitive joke that wasn't funny in the
first place access granted
why do they call this a firewall just
accessing the account right and if it's
an app on Alex's phone he would already
be logged in my point is this firewall I
like you just the way you are but I had
a plan yeah and what was that plan
exactly jailbreak wanted to get to the
cloud and now that she's here is she
gonna do are there even any other emojis
here mass all I feel I know jeans
feeling mad and all but he was also
looking directly at the spot that just
surprised and captured it and even if
the super BOTS got through the firewall
via the email app which is some nonsense
even for this movie how did it end up in
the same spot as Dropbox movie does know
that there are different clouds right no
god damn it's thing is terrible no
problem I could take you right now said
no phone technician ever movie sets up
this whole adventure by saying there's
only one way to get to the cloud
but now you can get back on the phone
through Dropbox via Twitter
Dylan waits to kill protagonists for no
other reason than providing him with an
escape opportunity cliche jailbreak is
able to gain control of this spot
because of hack hack thingy-thingy tech
tech hack tech the thing the app
happened to be in
middle of the phone screen and that
resetting a phone to factory settings
works progressively by the physical
location of the apps on the interface
and that I gave up the will to live 30
minutes ago Jean you got this even
though Jean spent his entire life with
the ability to express different
emotions because he got turned down by
some girl a few minutes ago he's
completely lost his Emoto I'm in last
time I was in this cube I screwed
everything up gene and therefore movie
has time for this dammit movie you
forced me to see all this nonsense once
already puking it at me again is worth
at least 10 cents jailbreak now or 45
seconds ago when this would have been
effective hey excuse me Jesus Christ
this is a movie about ping emoji but
doesn't even know how to phone right I
mean say Alex unplugged the phone and
somehow stopped the delete and pretend
that's an actual thing that works but
still deleted when you delete an app
it's been gone so this restoration of
all the apps and everything within them
is the Bulbul in a big movie pile a bowl
add 100 more cents and after this moment
the emoji formerly known as gene went on
to rule tex topples and one of the
longest and most brutal regimes in
smartphone history and the andy garcia
and passengers award for shortest cameo
goes to sofia vergara your request to
launch a pop culture based dance craze
has been denied you know for a movie
that set itself up with the whole kids
are always on their phones narrative
there's been very little phone usage
which i guess is a good thing
considering this is only like the third
time the emojis have actually gathered
in your cubes
watch out for your cornhole but like you
are is a malfunction what is your major
malfunction numbnuts
huh feel my face welcome to the firewall
how may I help you
what is her name her name yes all right
it's not a question
space the final frontier
okay Billy super sounds of the seventies
weekend just keeps on coming
they could stay here with you like
forever forever forever ever forever
ever I'll be honest I've already
forgotten the emoji movie usually I'll
make a reference to the movies food
scenes to start out a nature boxset but
in this movie's case just can't remember
any of them
there was pizza I think all right
whatever emoji movie sucks the fuck more
than anything that I've ever fucked
before you know what doesn't suck
naturebox and stuff how many times have
I told you don't say and stuff right now
if you go to naturebox.com/tyler sent
off your first order when you use the
promo code since that's a significant
savings nature box snacks are healthier
and free of artificial colors and
flavors they have a huge variety and are
always adding new snacks and they
shipped to your door
I mean how easy is this just go to
naturebox.com/tyler sins and get 50% off
your first order from oh code sins don't
mess this up people don't screw it up